la jeunesse poignardé de christelle
blétry ces mots sont parmi les premiers
du réquisitoire de l'avocat général
philippe chassaigne
anticipant sur la plaidoirie de la
défense il réfute par avance les
arguments qui viserait à jeter le doute
sur la réalité du viol subi par la
victime
il s'appuie pour cela sur les
déclarations de pascal jardin lui même
lors de ses aveux ce point est important
car les peines prévues ne sont pas les
mêmes selon que le meurtre a été ou non
précédée d'un viol sur la rétractation
de l'accusé et sa version d'une relation
sexuelle consentie
philippe chassaigne s'emploie à
détricoter ce qu'il qualifie de tissu de
mensonges et de contradictions y at il
eu rencontre fortuite entre pascal
jardin et christelle ou préméditation
il n'exclut pas cette dernière en se
basant toutefois sur des indices assez
minces plus convaincant et le rappel de
l'agression commise par l'accusé en 2004
qui avait bien été précédé d'un repérage
pour finir l'avocat général déroulent
les rapports des experts psychologues
sur la double et inquiétante
personnalité de pascal jardin en 2017
dit il aux jurés la cour d'assises de
chalon avait déclaré pascal jardin
coupable de viol et de meurtre et
l'avait condamné à la perpétuité
assortie de 20 ans de sûreté
je vous demande aujourd'hui de prononcer
la même peine